les rues du centre-ville d'auxerre comme
ici d'un mois celle du lycée jacques
amyot ont été bloqués une bonne partie
de l'après midi
c'est la conséquence d'une opération de
six heures retour sur les lieux du crime
celui tueur en série michel fourniret
après avoir longtemps nié l'homme a
avoué avoir tué joanna parrish une jeune
assistante d'anglais au lycée jacques
amyot d'auxerre les faits remontent à
mai 1990 le corps nu de la britannique
est retrouvé à monéteau la jeune fille
alors âgée de 20 ans a été violée et
battue avant sa mort michel fourniret 76
ans est donc revenue sur les différents
lieux du crime
le voici sur ces images cet après-midi
barbe blanche et gilet pare balles sur
le dos entouré de policiers plus tôt le
cortège s'est rendu à la gare routière
et dans une rue près de la poste
toujours à auxerre mais la justice
espère surtout que michel fourniret
l'aidera à retrouver le corps d'une
autre victime dont il a avoué le meurtre
marie angèle domèce handicapé mental âgé
de 19 ans disparue en juillet 1988 dans
l'yonne après mon nez tôt ce matin au ca
d'après-midi et la sphère joanna parrish
la justice pourrait continuer ce travail
de terrain dans l'yonne demain et les
jours qui suivent mais cette fois ci le
tueur en série reviendrait sur le
meurtre de marie angèle domèce une autre
de ses victimes